bienvenidos de vuelta les prometí
trabajar un problema al final del vídeo
pasado así que este es el problema que
vamos a trabajar y verás que muchos son
de este estilo pues están pensados
justamente para que dejen familiarices
con las variables en que están
involucradas en la ley de la gravitación
de newton entonces quedamos que hay dos
planetas digamos está el planeta tierra
más o menos
y ahí está el planeta tierra muy bien y
teníamos un segundo planeta y que
déjenme pintarlo con verde que este
segundo planeta tenía la mitad del radio
y la mitad de la masa muy bien entonces
ahí está nuestro segundo planeta es
verde porque probablemente tiene vida o
qué sé yo entonces este azul es la
tierra este verde es un planeta pequeño
ok entonces la pregunta es la siguiente
de hecho aquí tenemos los datos verdad
el radio de este planeta pequeño es la
mitad del radio de la tierra mientras
que la masa del planeta pequeño es la
mitad de la masa de la tierra muy bien
entonces vamos a suponer que yo me
encuentro por aquí
me encuentro parado en la tierra y en
algún viaje interestelar llego a este
planeta pequeño extraño muy bien
entonces la pregunta que había surgido
en el vídeo anterior es qué fracción de
la fuerza que tenemos la fuerza de
gravitación que hay entre la tierra y yo
qué fracción de esa es la fuerza de
gravitación que hay entre el planeta
verde y yo ok y entonces qué es lo que
estoy pensando si me encuentro en este
planeta p qué qué tanta fuerza o qué
proporción hay entre la fuerza que hay
de la tierra y la fuerza que hay en este
planeta muy bien entonces recordemos que
la fuerza de gravitación en la tierra no
es otra cosa más que la constante de la
gravitación universal que denota vamos
como g
la masa digamos la masa no seré yo mi
masa ok por la masa de la tierra verdad
dividido entre el radio de la tierra al
cuadrado verdad y dijimos que en
realidad es la distancia entre los
centros de masa verdad y aunque no
quiero sentirme muy muy muy pequeño de
hecho soy más o menos alto pues al menos
si mi centro de masa que a lo mejor no
sé estar a un metro de altura de la
superficie pues realmente un metro
comparado con todo el radio de la tierra
es prácticamente nada así que podemos
despreciar el centro de masa que tengo
digamos no sé yo creo en el ombligo y
vamos a suponer que se encuentra en la
superficie de la tierra muy bien
entonces así es cómo calculamos la
fuerza de gravitación entre la tierra y
mi cuerpo ok entonces cuál sería la
fuerza de gravitación entre el planeta
pequeño y yo entonces esto sería la
constante de la gravitación universal
por mi masa
por mi masa por la masa del planeta
pequeño que en este caso es la mitad de
la masa de la tierra dividido entre el
radio del planeta pequeño dividido entre
el radio del planeta pequeño que es un
medio del radio de la tierra y por
supuesto eso hay que elevarlo al
cuadrado entonces qué es lo que nos da
esto esto es lo mismo que aquí por
ejemplo este medio lo podemos sacar
podemos sacar este medio este de aquí ok
que multiplica g por la masa mi masa
mi masa que también multiplica la masa
de la tierra y dividimos entre quien es
un medio al cuadrado es un cuarto verdad
por propiedades de los exponentes que
multiplica al cuadrado del radio de la
tierra verdad ahí lo tenemos entonces
podremos primero operar los números
tenemos un medio entre un cuarto un
medio entre un cuarto esto es lo mismo
que 4 sobre 2 que es 2 verdad entonces
dejen mejor todo esto sólo fue para
hacer rápidamente esas cuentas aunque
entonces tendremos dos veces quién
por mi masa o la masa del objeto que
estén calculando su fuerza por la masa
de la tierra / el radio de la tierra al
cuadrado y si eres muy observador ya
podrás darte cuenta quién es exactamente
esto esto de aquí pues es justamente la
fuerza de gravitación que hay en la
tierra verdad es exactamente la misma
expresión así que podemos concluir que
esto es dos veces la fuerza de
gravitación de la tierra lo cual es
bastante sorprendente verdad uno podría
pensar al inicio que la masa es muy
importante y mientras más masa tenga un
objeto mucha más fuerza de gravedad va a
tener pero aquí lo que nos queda claro
es que no sólo es eso aunque el planeta
pequeño justamente tiene menos masa en
realidad el factor importante aquí
también es el radio cómo se disminuyó el
radio a la mitad es incluso un poco más
importante que la masa porque al
disminuir la mitad
masa y el radio resultó que se duplicó
la fuerza de gravitación así que esto
nos está demostrando que a distancias
más cortas las fuerzas tienden a hacer
mucho mucho más fuerte es verdad y de
hecho eso es porque está elevado al
cuadrado y eso es lo que nos da la
importancia de la distancia o del radio
digamos que estemos considerando que
allí de hecho algo que quería aclarar en
el vídeo anterior era que cuando estamos
pensando en gravedad por ejemplo a lo
mejor ustedes tienen aquí el planeta
tierra
y lo tienen más o menos yo sé que no
circular pero no importa y digamos que
tienen digamos una nave espacial
en una nave espacial que está
recorriendo la galaxia o el sistema
solar qué sé yo entonces cuando pensamos
en la gravedad siempre pensamos como que
la tierra ejerce una fuerza de atracción
hacia el objeto verdad es decir la
tierra está jalando al objeto hacia su
centro de masa no sé por ejemplo
podríamos pensar que a lo mejor aquí hay
una fuerza de atracción de un millón de
newtons y es a las 6 newtons ok y de
hecho eso es eso lo podríamos calcular
utilizando la ley de la gravitación
universal verdad la es la constante g
por la primera masa por la segunda más
ha dividido entre la distancia al
cuadrado ahora quiero que observen muy
bien esta fórmula porque si se dan
cuenta esta fórmula es simétrica en el
sentido de que no importa si estamos
hablando de la nave espacial o del
planeta tierra en realidad la fuerza de
atracción aplica para ambos objetos eso
nos está diciendo que también
la nave espacial está ejerciendo una
fuerza de atracción hacia su centro de
masa está atrayendo a la tierra hacia su
centro de masa también con una fuerza de
un millón de newtons ahora porque uno
podría ver que que la lámpara la nave
espacial si se acerca a la tierra y la
tierra no se acerca a la nave espacial
de hecho creo que ya vimos esto en algún
vídeo anterior pero esto es
esencialmente por la aceleración verdad
la fuerza depende de la masa y la
aceleración aquí la masa es muy pequeña
quiere decir que la aceleración tiene
que ser muy grande aquí la masa es muy
grande y lo cual quiere decir que la
aceleración es pequeña quizás a lo mejor
sería interesante pensar que ocurriría
con dos personas que se encuentran
flotando en el espacio exterior verdad
a lo mejor hay dos personas flotando en
el espacio exterior
y uno podría lo mejor pensar cuál es la
fuerza de atracción que hay entre estos
dos personajes y si tú sustituye es
digamos masas no sé digamos quizás de 70
kilogramos de cada uno de ellos y
divides entre cierta distancia pues no
se podría ser muy pequeña a lo mejor un
metro y multiplicas por la constante de
gravitación universal te darás cuenta
que esa fuerza de atracción es muy muy
pequeña si estamos en el espacio de
verdad seguramente en el espacio hay
otras fuerzas de atracción mucho más
fuertes que la fuerza de gravedad para
hacer que dos personas se junten bueno
como sea nos vemos en el próximo vídeo